people returning from a country on the
red list have to quarantine
in a government approved hotel and that
is for 10
days i want to speak now to catherine
wainwright who's currently in a hotel
quarantined
at heathrow after arriving from abu
dhabi
earlier this week hello to you catherine
morning k how are you i'm okay i mean
that looks a very comfortable hotel but
you are going to have to be in that room
for 10 days how are you feeling about
that
uh so far all right actually i have to
say it's been better than i expected
there's an awful lot more facilities
here than um than we were anticipating
they're very organized uh the security
to get people in
uh and out when we first arrive handling
of your baggage the check-in
has all gone really well uh we can do
yoga classes we can do
some uh uh some exercise classes we get
to go out
uh every day uh they provide cleaning
products for us
so you can see there the uh you have to
do your own cleaning they'll do a bit of
basic laundry
for us whilst we're here as well but uh
there's additional room service
products if you if you want to be able
to get that and the best news 4k
is that they do order alcohol in so hey
so all is not lost all is not lost talk
to me about
getting it to heathrow you get to
heathrow
uh then what happens when you get off
the airplane
so uh you're escorted immediately onto a
bus and that takes you
i came into terminal 3 which is the new
red zone terminal purely for those
coming in from redless countries
there was a flight just after hours but
it was very very empty an awful lot of
staff though making sure that you're
escorted into the right place
uh depending on which hotel system uh
which hotel location
uh so there's me in my bags and i was
the only one in the queue uh coming to a
london hotel
and then you wait you're then escorted
onto another bus they are
uh spraying um all of the buses before
and after
that's your little slip that you get
that delineates where you're going the r
for me is the renaissance
the coach trip then as you leave the
hotel and then you arrive
as you leave the terminal rather and
then you arrive at the hotel
they've got your name details they check
everything against your passport
they need to check your passenger
locator form that you've got your
confirmed um hotel booking
and the obvious covert 19 test that
they're looking for as well
and were you segregated at all times uh
from people that were arriving
from green list and amber list countries
because of course that was a criticism
at heathrow previously
well i came into the red oni terminal so
we were all from redless countries but
talking to some of the staff last night
they were saying that there are still a
number of people coming into terminal 2
who will have transited through a
european country and so they are
eligible to come into terminal 2
but they are effectively going to a
quarantine hotel so i do think that
there are still a number of people that
are mixing
both from amber and red countries in
other parts of the of
heathrow so um what are you most
and least looking forward to for the
next 10 days
well the view is all right at the moment
so i at least i've got some outside
space
uh i think i'm least looking forward to
the fact that it's seven paces from the
front door
of the room to the window so uh to try
and get ten thousand steps in every day
is going to be a challenge
um but they do it out i understand for a
few minutes each day so we'll get some
fresh air
oh that's good and a final thought
before i let you go you
i mean this is the first flight i think
from abu dhabi into london heathrow
direct for something like four months
how good is it to be home and even if
you are spending the first 10 days in a
hotel
well it's great i've been away for six
months i partially live in abu dhabi so
uh but
i've had to delay coming back uh i've
missed my father's 80th birthday i
missed my sister's 50th birthday
but it was time to get back and i think
now to be back for the summer the
commitment to doing this in the hotel
uh is going to be well worth it uh but
it's uh it'll be a long ten days i think
and then it'll be great to see family
and
after a very very long time away okay so
when i did mine it uh
paint by numbers that's the way forward
it takes hours it's really um
irritating to start with and then you're
really focused and before you know it
the day's gone
thank you for the tip i'll grab that
from i get that delivered we can get
food and
and shopping delivered here so uh they
try and make it as easy as for us as
possible but
check in in another 10 days time see if
i'm still as optimistic and poor yeah
i did exactly that we'll do exactly that
catherine good to talk to you thanks
very much thank you